les salariés de l'usiné renault de
maubeuge ont repris le travail ce
mercredi après avoir remporté un bras de
fer avec leur direction
face à la mobilisation des employés du
site et de tout un territoire le
constructeur automobile a décidé de
revenir sur sa décision de délocaliser
sa production de kangoo à doué la
réunion au ministère de l'économie ce
mardi a poussé les dirigeants de la
marque au losange a renoncé le
gouvernement a conditionné l'octroi d'un
prêt de 5 milliards d'euros à
l'entreprise au maintien de l'emploi sur
le site nordiste
une victoire pour les 2100 employés mais
acquise dans un climat de méfiance
aujourd'hui je pense que nous sommes un
peu plus rassuré que ce que nous
l'étions avant de partir à paris
et surtout c'est d'avoir obtenu aussi
vite
cette victoire parce que c'est une
première victoire même si la guerre
n'est pas finie
c'est une première victoire parce que
nous resterons toujours sereins et
vigilants à ce que renault va par nous
proposer parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
sentons totalement trahi la part de
renault puisque une société qui était
mis à quelques mois sur le site avait
dit à nous syndicalistes salaires une
entreprise c'est à bien un site
aujourd'hui qu'ils n'ont aucune
inquiétude à avoir c'est bien le vôtre
votre avenir est tout tracé
alors que nous sommes dans son plan
d'économies renault il prévoyait de
délocaliser la production du véhicule
2023 envers nous et donc aujourd'hui
peut-on encore le croire
avant d'obtenir gain de cause tout un
territoire s'est mobilisée syndicaliste
salariés familles d'employés élus locaux
tous ont joué un rôle déterminant pour
sauver le site de maubeuge
mais l'incompréhension sur la volonté
des dirigeants de fermer leur usine la
plus productive en france est toujours
présente
d'abord c'est l'incompréhension par
rapport aux investissements de redon ils
ont décidé il ya trois quatre ans
d'investir 450 millions d'euros sur un
site pour le moderniser pour avoir un
nouveau une nouvelle production
donc il pensait à l'abri et quand cette
indiscrétion de la presse est arrivé
concernant les projets de renault
s'était complètement l'incompréhension
l'incompréhension par rapport aux
engagements des uns et des autres
investissements et l'incompréhension par
rapport à leur investissement propre
pour dire voilà on est les meilleurs et
on doit le rester et on a fait nos
preuves et on comprenait pas donc c'est
aussi
à une entreprise qui fait dans la
compréhension l'accord trouvé lors de la
table ronde à bercy préserve les 2100
emplois du site nordiste
au delà de 2023 des négociations doivent
aussi commencer dès la semaine prochaine
avec la direction de renault pour
trouver un nouveau véhicule à construire
après cette échéance